animaux j'évite tous morts tout tout
une angoisse chez l'homme qui n'est pas connue
fait une idée
Bien
une catastrophe lui a dit non parce que
il y a quelques jours, nous étions venus quand pas
il y avait bien des incendies et c'était le
la nature vivante et non les animaux de la
flore faune et bon a voir a voir maintenant
le tout porté donne vraiment un
la tristesse donne une immense tristesse
[Musique]
J'ai été beaucoup d'animaux, nous avons vu que
la route vient mourir tout près
cherchant l'espace où il n'atteint pas le
le feu mais généralement de la fumée et
la fièvre est ce qui les tue, non
sera à nouveau affecté car
Je dis le jaguar ou celui qu'on appelle le tigre
généralement par les gens le lion qui
s'en nourrit alors en n'ayant pas
pas trouver ça
ces animaux vont aussi
il semble qu'il y ait des problèmes d'obésité
déshydratation chez ces animaux
[Musique]